this morning we have a special story
ahead of this Father's Day first
sergeant Michael Maybury has trained
thousands of paratroopers for the Army's
82nd Airborne Division
now he's jumping from aircraft with his
son private will Mabry the 18-year old
is being deployed to take part in
training exercises with Allied forces
it's rare for a father and son to serve
in the same army brigade let alone the
same battalion we are honored to have
them share this unusual experience with
us why are you doing the army I mean I
know the story but America knows so well
teaching martial arts full-time now we
had our own house and then 9/11 happened
I'll never forget that was on a Tuesday
and I went to the recruiter that same
Friday and so I said I want to be
airborne and be at Fort Bragg and they
said come on in how did it feel whenever
you had to go and we had to stay that
was tough the saying goodbye was the
hard part
but staying focused on the mission
through each day at a time that was my
rock and knowing you guys were here when
I came back it didn't really hit me as
hard because I wasn't really aware of
what was going on it was kind of normal
and in a way but I mean it's still still
rough saying goodbye how was it like
going over the person well each
deployments different I've been to Iraq
twice I've been to Afghanistan obviously
what we do is dangerous but getting to
do our technical skills in a combat area
not a whole lot of people can say they
do that dad dad dad you're getting ready
to go to Europe for a training exercise
are you excited yeah I'm I'm nervous
though I've never been there even out of
country so maybe it'll be fun though
great training you focus on what you
have to do in your job but I'm told get
paid to do it you told yeah and do it
you're told what was the life for you
growing up around the Fort Bragg and the
paratroopers I thought I fruit up with a
paratrooper mentality just that
mentality of go go go and sometimes you
take me in to work I see people in
uniform it gave me more of a realization
of what you did and how important it is
to have a military so all of my
deployments and time gone to debt
Knights have an impact on your decision
the fame thing it maybe it motivated me
more because they've made it we meet one
maybe you want to go fight interesting I
got to celebrate your first jump with
you which is awesome for me what was it
like to jump with your dad have an
airplane it's crazy experience and like
I'd never thought I'd ever do it and so
it actually happened so it's cool having
you right behind me so for me highlight
of my career I got to do the the jump
master personal inspection on your
parachute here's my only son and I'm
getting to inspect your equipment to
make sure you're gonna have a safe exit
then we're sitting on the aircraft now
they're flying I see this this young
grown man and the parachute harness
sitting next to me but my mind I saw my
five year old little buddy so a lot of
emotion
how is everyone still different from
from from my my experience
well I I came in a little older I was
already 28 so mentally I was more mature
you're in better shape than I am
you're a football star here in high
school and you ran track how did that
your athletics in high school help you
with your your training going in the
army I felt like I was immensely ready
for a challenge just like I told you
sports you know do your best and have
fun I want you to be successful I've
been very successful my career I'm here
if you want me to help you I've told you
this before I want to be your dad first
not your NCO but if you want help you
ask for it and I'll absolutely help you
be successful your career but the
thought of him packing the parachute is
used packing your child's parachute
before you both leap out of a plane
imagine if something happened it just
that Star Trek scene where Captain Kirk
goes after Sulu any Star Trek but such a
lovely piece I love the bay there we're
clearly talking about some of this stuff
for the first time which is really
interesting really interesting you
sometimes you don't know what your son
is thinking when you go off to work and
as a son you don't realize that dad is
still seeing you with that five-year-old
you have exactly all right I love you
I'm sorry so beautiful all right thanks
to First Sergeant Michael Mabry and
private will Mabry and all of the
soldiers serving at Fort Bragg who
welcomed us into their dining room